D
KAITLAN S WIHERE US.
WHAT MORE DO W KNO THISLL>> YEA
TURNED A
THEWOD. AEMKA
TH GOVERNMENT HAD WIT
GOVERNORS ANDCIS ON THIS
CALL AND HE CHOSE START ITY
LASHING OUT THEANDEM HAD BEEN W.
THEYO START CRACKING DOW
PRTEE
VIOLTHE STREETS OFTESTOCK OF TH
OBTAINED.KVERLI W DOW WRENS A T
WHOLE RL AND IOUSE NAT DI WS
S
HAPPENINISIB
UP AND NATIONAL ARD? THEFHECOUNN
TERRIBLE, IT IS TERRIBLE. NIGHT
ANGELES IS TERRIBLE. END HEAYS
IMPRIN SOME OF THESEPROTESTERS
S.
E L SNT
WETABLE.
US G M TRYIN COMING R >> WESORR
OR PARTICIPATIT
OURRI SOCIETY AT
LARGE AIGHER
MODELODE  WHAOLL.I DIDN'TTO CU
TOEEREAN A SECON
ST PRESI ISSUED.
FIRST, HESS ONE AAGO.NE TELNGPR
START TO THE REF ATH OF GEORGE
PENINGHE
ITRHAD NEXTSOME P HAVEM HIM EN
HE ADDRESS TFT WITH HIMHE AEL T
DE FLOYD AVE SEEN  THE COUNTRY A
RIG .INSTEA MESSAIY
COME FROM T IN ADDI T E SAIDNSA
KIND OVALFFARDEN ADESS,UL  TOSP.
THEID NEED TO GO ND SAY
E
CHARLOTTE, WHAT WAS TGE
PENT TIME TOET W
LEADERAN
THAT MORNING SITTING TRE
LISTENING FOR ABOUT AN
T
ERND SO HHIN-AMERICANPLUNTRY.
HE PULLED DOWISBOUT A LOTUT THE
ONOMICACHA
AFRICAER TAKEN G  PANDEMI A
HE WERERE ASVERY,
WOU ON FIX SOME OF INSTITUTION.
THAT'S TE'S BEEN ING FTARTFCAMP.
TAKE A LISTEN TO WHAT HE HAD TO
Y.
>>VE IS
LET SOM >> ALSOAYS
RELEASING SOMECONOC
PROPOSALSELIN HCONOMIC
AS DEPE COURSE OF TEX
IN WES
A B WOMAN HIS
MATE,TSSIDERING T
W ASESIDENALABLE WIT M LANTA,